this fool is sitting right here for that
seventh game of the Western Conference
final in astonishment basketball kid
don't dawn on that play both guys four
determined to get a play for their team
hardly
[Applause]
[Music]
Robinson was a great shot blocker
Patrick Ewing
scammer right here
[Applause]
step back
baby the game winner
Dantzler dancing again
away the love game that's so effective
between me and James art great dish
underneath cappella sit in plus a foul
he feels like his guy is hung up the
rotation a little bit late and this is
where a cappella how about that pass
right between the defender
[Music]
James points by Hartman
a 34 to 20 quarter and the Rockets Gasol
wants it against capella
yep Sheldon stole about Chris Paul
forcing the league in steals a 2.1 a
game and harden tux he's got a dozen
berries off the bench the double-team is
cordless came over and harden just went
right
flavor there's no rent protection when
Gobert sent mussels James Harden to the
basket he's got eight points
Crowder is too cool jazz have 5 degrees
and James with another nice backdoor
play there easy
dump the other end of this scene Chris
Paul dribbles at James and then James's
goes backdoor
watch how Gobert comes in late because
he had to stay up high with propel he's
only the number one scorer in the NBA
star watch the dunk first no
[Music]
back to where it started
this behind the back
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
behind the bus yes
he could do it all
that's what you call behind the back
crossover step back
subjects have capable
tan and the hoof ooh pardon says okay I
know we both showing that we the best
cards in the game take that right all
game longing to see James stepping back